[Music]
in all in your head news it's on your
[ __ ] head it's all in your [ __ ]
head submitted by sushi apprentice I
wanted to do that but go on let's talk
about the topic today oh that's nice job
a new study reports that simply thinking
about coffee is enough to wake you up
there's so many times I go I wish I had
coffee I wish I uh I gotta fall asleep
that was me yesterday I'm not that
dependent on coffee thank God just like
the time addicted to the ritual there
like the warmth and the way it feels
know what feels really good caffeine you
sleep seven hours yeah oh yeah whoo it's
like eight hours yo when one night it's
very rare and very like if I sleep eight
hours straight
it's very few and far between but when I
do it feels like I'm a pre-workout but
have you done it before midnight that's
the [ __ ] there's a difference Tim I
don't
I got try to [ __ ] yeah you know my
favorite is my favorite is sleeping
eight hours and then around 2:00 or 3:00
take a one-hour nap that's a lot of
sleep I do that that feels but I don't
take a one-hour nap it's like a
20-minute nap or sometimes only need 20
yeah I sometimes I'll sleep and then I'm
like so energizing oh [ __ ]
yeah I'm ready though cuz if I sleep
more than that then I get then I just
want to stay sleeping yeah I think - our
- oh my god if I take a nap that means
you're sleep-deprived it will be 2 hours
to be my sleep time you know that -
three hours oh damn that lasted like
almost three years there she was ages
you
you're gonna you're you're like a 40
year old man now anymore I sleep like a
solid like five now five that's how much
Steve sleeps - but I told you about to
yourself so Steve just doesn't check
that mark at all he gets tired from
walking he can walk um like we walk out
of a mile and a half around our
neighborhood like when we go on our
evening walks but anything above like if
you're on the treadmill anything above
like a 4.0 maybe his his [ __ ] genius
humor come from him being unhealthy yeah
maybe but he wasn't always like that
yeah
like maybe that's we were talking about
scuba thing I think he was able to pass
the scuba thing when he was healthy swim
yet the like you swim like I don't know
how many like maybe 200 meters it was
pretty long and then you have to tread
water like just like this for 15 minutes
straight he's really strong though he's
unusually strong like very strong he can
look more crazy amounts like he could
lift up but without working God he
didn't lift like a lot but he could not
he has no endurance cardio eyes no
nerves
yeah this is farm boy stirring yeah
alright so there were these researchers
at Monash University University and the
University of Toronto Manoj more like
[ __ ] let's keep it go anyway so then
they recorded their findings in the
journal consciousness and cognition and
they wrote that people may be more
aroused simply after we rose yeah the
one that's actually good we didn't say
arouse we like okay we see that happen
in threes like that you're really good
you're really good we'll wake up again
let's get back on it think of coffee
people would be more aroused after
walking by a coffee shop and would they
be more aroused but at a more downstream
level their decision-making might shift
as well is what they're claiming do you
think it's the smell that's triggering
it oh I love the smell of [ __ ] I think
that wakes me up so that's part of it
and then they were also saying because
they were conducting these tests and
they had they started with participants
being cue to think about either coffee
or tea so they had two groups
geez awesome then coffee any [ __ ]
there me too I don't have the same smell
like that like Oh Roman smell I like
coffee know the smell but I like I like
coffee with chocolate smell and that's
funny because I don't like chocolate but
if I if I if that's like combined and
uhm
ouka yes that's pretty good because the
coffee's masked there's nothing a
different like caffeine hide I think I
like the matcha hi like they like the
caffeine boost from ma chick is more
smooth and you're not jittery and stuff
like that right but it's longer but the
ritual of coffee with the like you do
smell and everything well I've been
doing it because it comes like yeah I
mean every morning I've been making the
watch a little like that me too I do it
twice a week yeah so then like I'll do
it in a little Bowl and in the width yes
I do it in the afternoon but Coffee has
to be in the morning I can't start with
that you know what's tough about matcha
though it does whiten your teeth so
instead of making a yellow makes it
wider
he's not my coffee and actually tried it
cuz I'd do it every Tuesday Thursday I
go this my only Tuesday Thursday I said
I brushing your teeth he just cuz of
days that I train train I got pretty
workout your hand in your pants when you
see that get your hand out there
comfortable you got an A+ in science
today god of again oil change excuse me
sir
no more Jiffy Lube for you so one group
thought about coffee and the other one
didn't and the other one thought about
tea oh and then so they also had this
other study where they would come up
with advertising slogans for coffee or
tea depending what group they were in
and then in the other studies they read
either a mocked up health news story
about the benefits of drinking coffee
and then the other one was about tea
they found that for the coffee group
they had like higher levels of that
stuff just by thinking about it yeah oh
and they did mention that if this this
worked mainly for the Western countries
that have coffee yeah coffee culture and
then when they did it with the eastern
that don't have that it didn't work but
the tea probably worked for them they
didn't mention that specifically but
they did mention about the coffee yeah
we've just been so like conditioned do
you think coffee I've just been having
it every morning since I was 14 and it
just teen [ __ ] what the hell so it
feels like if some morning is not
complete without it yeah I used to
for school and I thought for sure
puppies you can look like how other
people feel when they smoke cigarettes
Oh drink black coffee I do right now
like usually it's black or it has a
splash of almond milk but right now it's
black because I'm on this like special
you've been conditioned girl remember
the best part of waking up is Folgers in
your cup yeah we never bought fold what
hat do they still have those commercials
this Bolger still right I don't know
soldier this round I don't know if they
still have the course I really do like
the smell of coffee though it smells
good really nice it makes me feel like
I'm at home
my parents about it yeah I like the
smell of coffee beans - hmm I don't even
eat bacon but if I smell bacon like it
makes me feel like I'm at home - because
my parents used to make like bagel call
bottom making breakfast for a lot of
people I can't think about it I have to
ingest it yeah well it's not like you're
gonna get the full theme effects of your
drinking it is just that there's they're
saying here that oh your heart since the
beat a little faster just a little
faster so like for example I was the
average heart rate for the coffee group
was 76 beats per minute and then the tea
group was 70 beats per minute because
that's they have an addiction who's
gonna say I wonder what would happen if
they thought about someone they loved or
something they love if it would be the
same effect because I love coffee and I
think that's more what makes my heart
beat is that we get to have coffee and I
get excited how Q you get butterflies
when you be good coffee I do this is
just tough Steve you know everything is
just visualization I mean they they did
this study with people that actually
worked out people that thought about
working out and then they spent one hour
just lifting weights in their head or
like playing piano and practicing piano
and then people that just imagined that
they got better they got healthier their
heart rate got better all this [ __ ] - I
was also reading this study about
rewards like rewarding yourself so
people that thought about going to the
gym but then change their mind didn't
actually go still felt like they
deserved rewards out there that's me for
sure treat themselves
we're just for thinking about going to
they just like people that post those
motivational quotes yeah but they never
actually do anything
yeah but they H tagged hustle they're so
inspired to be more inspired hated when
people do that it's like I always see it
consistently cuz I'm on Twitter a lot
not they're like dude if you want to go
out there you got to go and get it and
it's like a ten-year-old kid and I'm
like the [ __ ] have you done you [ __ ]
sperm like you've done nothing you were
just born yesterday shut the [ __ ] up I
got bullied and now he's like I gotta
find a way to hope for more yeah you
heartless piece of [ __ ] I don't give a
[ __ ] why you give a [ __ ] less lion just
cuz yeah boy you got that [ __ ]
blowing smoke up a PC it was a doll with
the pull-string it would just be like I
don't give a [ __ ] people it again is
like I'll punch you in your [ __ ] face
that's right look last dude I don't give
a [ __ ] man
I like give less [ __ ] now that's true
you know cuz like when you were in high
school I give [ __ ] about different
things so actually yeah but you kind of
you manage your [ __ ] really well I do
[ __ ] management yeah yeah yeah here's a
new book coming out this month i
pre-ordered it what is it called
how did that even give a [ __ ] even some
more maybe the sequel to the art of not
giving a [ __ ] is how did I even give a
[ __ ] some more Obama [ __ ] you thought
you gave bucks before I think the
ultimate I think that's Buddhism right
there is like that's the ultimate like
when you reach enlightenment it's like I
don't even give a [ __ ] you know how much
I would give a [ __ ] I give a [ __ ] about
this world
that's why Bart's mom doesn't care if
she does when I know she does she does
know she's lying she's like she's like
the hashtag hustle people where I think
she's preaching to herself because he's
putting it
Debbie says
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]